just uh I do I do have a question
whether whether you leave this in or not
but like so I'm three years eight months
seven days sober without drinking or
drugs uh no no weed so that's been about
like a year and a half okay wow congrats
dude
so like it's to me you know it just it
really seems to be getting more
difficult okay right and um
was there did did you go through that
similar around this time
um and is there just like
I am a big fan of the 12-step process
right and I think that that it's
demonstrable the you know
validity of it because millions and
millions of people have come before us
yeah and uh you know basically the proof
is in that yeah you know like there's a
book which outlines the 12-step process
and it nobody's ever tried to rewrite it
nobody's gonna like there's just one
book since 1939. yeah and then you know
that the consensus is they got it right
and the people who uh followed that book
so the book outlines the 12-step process
and the the point at which I believe the
obsession to drink alcohol and take
drugs is lifted comes when one completes
a thorough fifth step
I think that that like uh just going by
that you know like step four is where
you make an inventory of everything that
that uh
upsets you and and like it's pretty
incredible the way everything that I've
said to you
falls into three categories there's
resentment
you know if you're like just pissed off
somebody then that that's upsetting
there's fear
and there's guilt so so the the
inventory process well Harm's done to
others that that brings guilt you feel
guilty because you harm somebody fair
enough yeah so uh so you make a a list
of everything that you can think of that
you feel resentful about
you make a list of everything you can
think of that you feel fearful about you
make a list of everything you can think
of that you feel guilty about and then
uh yeah you know you take these lists
that's step four you take these lists to
somebody and you talk through it all
with them yeah get it all off your chest
and the idea is that you break down
what your part is in the resentments you
break down what like appropriate
indicated action you can do to address
your fears and in this process you
really dismantle everything that screws
you up you you take the power out of
everything that I've said to you and
once you've once you've done that like
you don't like that the edge is taken
out there like everything that you're
using the drugs and alcohol to soothe is
soothed yeah so so yeah I think the
difference is that like if you haven't
done that and you're not drinking or
doing drugs you're like what they say is
like white nothing and so it's like that
stuff's still inside of you you're just
not covering it up and more so it
probably will get harder yeah and just
maybe eating you alive and then when you
do take the power to that or like when
you let go of like a secret and like
telling somebody
that takes a lot of the power out of it
too and then for me when I did that like
my life got better and better
it but up until that point now sober
it's just like it's like I had an
infection inside of me and I wasn't
taking I wasn't numbing out to like to
be distracted by it like I was finally
not doing drugs and then like the
infection was like oh [__] it's like
painful inside yeah it just kept getting
more painful and painful and I think the
steps is like cutting you open doing the
work is like you know having a doctor
kind of clean you out and Stitch you
back up and getting the infection out
I've heard people say I never suffered
from alcoholism until I got sober yeah
right and that's like uh because
because the
the the drinking alcohol and taking
drugs is not the disease that is if
anything a remedy disease yeah that's a
symptom of the disease the disease is
centered in our mind and the
characteristics of the disease are
restless irritability discontent like
we're just plain uncomfortable in our
own skin and we need to to soothe that
discomfort so we cover it up with drugs
and alcohol you take away the drugs and
alcohol
you still have the disease so you got to
do something to to address that
discomfort to dismantle the the ills of
the disease and that's where the
inventory process comes you literally do
an inventory of everything that makes
you uncomfortable
and it's the it's the raddest thing it
is it's super red was the fourth really
difficult for you oh my God I I got the
fourth step blues and landed up in a
psych ward oh really yeah
oh yeah
I went back and forth between steps four
and five you know I would write out a
bunch and I would go and then talk
through it I'd go back and write more
I'd go back now were you for the fourth
were you going back as far as you could
like of course as long as you remember
yeah yeah yeah yeah well yeah well no
because at first I was just like dude
that was [__] eight years old that's
weird but that's where like somebody you
know what do they say if it's hysterical
it's historical so it's like it comes
from somewhere for sure but yeah every
time I would go to my sponsor to do the
fifth and and he would be like no like
you need to go you need more you need to
go back further okay
the more data that you can crunch the
more effective the process is yeah like
you get out of it what you put in so if
you like really thoroughly put
everything that's ever bothered you into
it yeah and what's great about doing the
this this process is that
as you get into it as you break down all
of the these things on your inventory
patterns emerge and you realize oh my
God like I always trip myself up by
doing this should you identify patterns
you identify behaviors which don't serve
you and you can they call it uncovered
discover discard and you just kind of
let go but the problem I had and why I
wound up in the psych ward for the
second time with three months of
sobriety
I am had
in my you know in my inventory I just
put down like I I was I was looking at
things that I had done that that I just
felt like a terrible person for having
done but in my my harm done others
inventory the things I felt guilty about
and I just arrived at the conclusion
that I was a terrible person and did not
deserve forgiveness and that the only
thing that was going to work was I had
to kill myself [__] yeah and uh and then
I was at a you know one of our meetings
and I'd shared that I said all the work
I'm putting into my steps I feel like
I'm just getting out self-hatred I just
feel like I hate myself I can't forgive
myself and I just want to blow my brains
out now how long did that how many
months in yeah yeah I was three months
sober at that time but how long did that
feeling last that self-hatred from doing
that um well I I that that meeting took
place on the hospital grounds that had a
psych ward on those the the good people
of the group just they lovingly walked
me across the grounds to the psychord
yourself yeah yeah and and I was with it
I was like hey I need to be in here yeah
so I checked myself into that psych ward
they're like pill boys back
while I was in that psych ward and I
couldn't get out for like three weeks
but while I was in there I was reading
that same book which is uh you know
which outlines the 12 steps and um
there's a chapter in that book
um
which I was I was reading it and uh it
says that the the history of every
alcoholic is plagued with specters of
the unexpected the things every
alcoholic has a history of of things
that they've done they're humiliating
tragic you know like sad even like it's
like funny you know but like but like
the the the sum total of any alcoholics
past
like is comprised of a lot of stuff that
that you would think
you gotta like it says one would think
that the past of an alcoholic that that
for that future happiness was dependent
upon forgetfulness of the past like you
could never be so ashamed of what you've
done in your past that you can never be
happy in your future unless you're able
to swipe it all under the rug load it up
into the closet throw away the key and
never think about it ever again if
you're going to be happy after you've
done all that crap it says but art and
it says but our history shows the exact
opposite that in fact the the tragic
humiliating you know like upsetting the
past of the alcoholic is actually the
like uh the one of the greatest if not
the absolute greatest asset to the
alcoholic because having overcome that
terrible past yeah
now the alcoholic is equipped to help
other people overcome their own past by
Rising above it moving forward moving
past it now we can we can help others do
the same that's why the the book says uh
no matter how far down the scale we have
gone well like uh
then we'll see how our past can be
useful to others so in that reading of
that I was reading that book I'm in the
psych ward I just think I'm a terrible
it just kind of clicked for me like oh
maybe like
all this awful crap that I did which I
feel so just terrible about and I feel
like I can't forgive myself maybe the
answer isn't to kill myself maybe the
answer is to just stop being that
terrible person like that's what the
inventory process is for is yeah
uncovered discover discard like maybe I
just let go of that that's the whole
point don't dwell on like how ashamed I
am but just stop being that stop doing
that and so when I got out of that psych
ward I take myself back into rehab again
I started over from scratch and and I
just took the the position that I don't
want to be that guy anymore and and that
then I shifted my
memorization my perspective and ever
since then
it's then and really that that same
shame of all that crap I did became the
fire under my ass to to stay sober for
the right reasons what are you thinking
about when he says that
that is just like a great example for me
to know I mean first off that like I
didn't do the steps I haven't done the
steps so like first off I think that
that's like the real big move that I
need to do the second is that like you
seem to have this
idea that see like my my biggest cons my
biggest thing that keeps [__] with my
head is that
I'm at the point now where it's almost
like the there was like a high from
getting sober and proving to myself that
I could do that and it seems like that
somehow running low and now I feel like
I'm like was
more interesting or more fun or
something
being [__] up and I know I know that's
wrong I know that's wrong and I can say
it out loud it's just about I need to
convince myself and I just look at what
you're saying with like you have this
real passion behind you that like I mean
you've lived one of the craziest lives
of anyone I've ever known that part was
easy for me because
looking at my professional career
before I got sober like I put a lot of
work into developing a skill set that I
could utilize for you know the the style
of entertainment that you know that I
became known for yeah I put a lot of
effort into it there was like some
legitimate skill behind it there was a
lot of creativity there was like there
was it wasn't just dumb you know there
was there was work and there was
creativity and it gradually as I got
worse on with drugs and alcohol it
devolved and by the end I I mean I was
just look how wasted I am like Oh and it
was like Stevo peed on this you know
like it was just where could I be
inappropriate pull out my wiener pee on
something like a Stevo peed on a red
carpet you know like Stevo's smoked pot
here like
there was just like it would be an
airplane right it's all done an airplane
it just became kind of pathetic that
like that like gone was the real
creativity gone was the like the the
effort like the it just became a sad
pathetic guy you know and um it's scary
to get sober but I mean
I'm way I've demonstrated like many
times over
to like to the power of the nth degree
that I'm far more creative for sure and
fun yeah and sobriety than I was
particularly at the end of my run with
drugs and alcohol yeah
yeah so
I mean
submit to you that if you feel like
you're going to be more fun creative
interesting on drugs and alcohol
I mean in our literature it says
head on over to the nearest bar room and
see what happens you know like
um
I I have trouble believing that that uh
there's gonna be any
yeah because if I think about drinking
I'm not thinking about like drinking I'm
thinking about getting [__] up and
like I was talking with my therapist and
I said man dude like I just wish I could
be normal and drink like a six pack of
beer a night and chill because it's
funny that like you think that's normal
no they it's not and she's like that's
you're thinking like I like I want I
fantasize about getting I don't
fantasize about enjoying the hit of weed
and it's like I just fantasize about
being [__] blazed on the beach all
day like that's what I think about you
know it's not enjoyable I think about
the most extreme of like that showing
and being a fall down drunk yeah what
you know and like falling asleep in a
dumpster yeah I like it yeah
romanticize yeah you were talking about
like wikowski yeah you know
I want to be so like
crazy on drugs that I haven't slept for
three days and then like people walking
around who aren't actually there yeah
you think about the fifth day how fun
that would be you know it's like yeah
the thinking's off yeah right and the
other thing too that like uh
people who are not alcoholic never
wonder if they're alcoholic you know
like yeah I'm not sure but you know well
no it's like you know how somebody's an
alcoholic if it's like my sister's a
normian if I was like when was the last
time you drank she's like like four
months ago yeah like hey mod when's the
last time you drank your like three
years seven days six hours
[Laughter]
exactly bro exactly yeah Sami I don't
know I mean like the other thing too
and this is I say this a lot that
in my view the worst situation to be in
is to
kind of be alcoholic yeah you have
alcoholism but not too bad yeah because
in that situation there's no like black
and white definite like need to address
it and because there's not that it's not
that bad it can go on and and it does go
on because it's not that bad so it just
you never do anything about it and like
you're it it's just bad enough to slow
you down to compromise your ability to
accomplish your goals you're talking
about like the functioning addict yeah
like eating soup with a fork it's just
it's just bad enough to interfere with
your relationships to make you not
realize your potential yeah you know but
not bad enough that it's got to stop so
it continues and and you know it years
slip through your fingers and then the
years turn into decades and next thing
you know you're you're like old and you
think yeah damn I blew it yeah as
opposed to if you have alcoholism so
dramatically badly that it has to be
addressed and that was the boat I landed
in very lucky to land in that boat
because I was 33 years old and I had to
do something about it yeah now I'm
coming up on 15 years of not being
impeded by drugs and alcohol you know
and by like you know for 15 years I've
largely been able to focus my energy and
my ability on what I want to do now of
course to Scott's point that like
chasing [__] around it like really
impedes one's ability to accomplish
their goals but then I addressed that
too and now I've got I've got this great
relationship with my girl and like
there's no distraction so I'm like a
laser just like
you know like laser focused and
nothing's in my way wasting my time or
and so like to me
that's the yeah the ultimate people like
when they talk about you know Heaven
Heller like Purgatory like the in
between like my definition of hell would
be
being high as [__]
with another person that's high as [__]
talking about like dreams like you know
I can't wait to do this like that would
be my definition of hell oh dude I was
just sitting here okay dude like yeah
we're gonna do this we'll do that and
then it's like or being 50 or 60 talking
about the Glory Days you know it's like
right now in my life it's it's full and
there's goals and there's things to look
forward to on a daily basis like that's
why I got sober I I one of the things I
talk about is I try really really
[__] hard to travel the world when I
was getting [__] up and like I maybe
did like 10 countries you know and I was
like broke and I was just kind of like
I'd be in Germany sleeping on the floor
you know on a park bench with a
newspaper over me or like just [__]
staying at a shitty hostel and trying to
work for two weeks to you know an hour
whatever and then when I got sober
uh and [__] we've been to like 40
countries together you know it's just
kind of like things just happen so
easily where it's like I I have it's
like it's not like when I try my hardest
to do something when I'm [__] up and
I'm in the wrong State of Mind like I
said eating soup with a fork it's like
you're just working so hard to [__]
not get full and then once you kind of
like just give up and be like all right
[__] it I Surrender [__] just pops off
pops off yeah you know so we're big fans
of sobriety
I mean my whole life changed when when I
changed it really did yeah and then you
met the one yeah well that that 100 that
and then I mean just everything in my
life I mean just my mom being like I
look at you and I feel like I have my
son back you know what I'm saying was
was like a big thing but there was just
such a and this is what I need hearing
all this is so great because
like I said and it's probably I mean you
guys could tell me it's probably the
wrong way to think about it is that like
there was so much
um like like I said like a high attached
to the fact of proving to myself that I
could do it
um whereas yeah so that and yeah that's
I gotta be done with that right and and
just realize that it's more to it than
just the proving to myself here's the
thing I think this is probably the most
I feel broken like at this point right
now with just like not knowing
how to move forward like everything felt
like I was moving forward at such a
great rate and I just like don't want to
end that
um
whether one is an alcoholic or not take
take that completely aside and we're not
talking about addiction on any level
we're just talking about being a human
being okay I think that most people's
biggest problem is that they have not
identified the thing that they are just
ultimately passionate about because it
is impossible to hit a bullseye if you
are not aiming at a Target and a lot of
people just don't have they don't have a
purpose they don't have that thing that
they want to do and so without
identifying a goal it's impossible to
accomplish a goal so people are just
kind of wandering through life without
like a goal and that's the biggest
problem I think
um you know you gotta identify what it
is that you're passionate about and then
life takes on this this uh this man
magical purpose and this opportunity to
be fulfilled that otherwise you can't
have
so for you I I hear you saying that that
uh you know life is like you know the
the high of proving to myself that I
could live without drugs and alcohol is
kind of wearing off and now I'm
wondering am I more more interesting if
I pick up drugs Now call again and I
would say that probably number one you
wouldn't be thinking that if uh if there
wasn't some danger there and number two
I think you could eradicate that entire
line of of thought by just
like
recommitting yourself to identifying
your purpose you know like if you if you
just sit down if you just ask yourself
I'm getting ready to go on this epic
tour got a new album coming out like
what where is the void coming from you
know like are you concerned that that
now that you've got this album out like
that that now you need creative juices
to start writing the next album and so
you're insecure about that admit to
making you question your sobriety like
you know like get to the root of what
the concerns are yeah the why and just
keep asking why yeah and I mean
lean into it yeah I would say you know
and and if
if you feel like you you've got more
experimenting to do they that you need
to go out there and and get loaded smoke
a joint you know like whatever it is
just uh
be careful maybe not even be careful but
just be be ready to identify
like uh just a loop of of
counterproductive yeah [__] you know
Groundhog's Day yeah of loserville yeah
I mean yeah I mean maybe you're maybe
you're not an alcoholic maybe or not you
know there's only one way to find out
and that's just crash and burn but like
but my concern would be that only having
alcoholism a little bit so it just goes
on forever and just slows you down and
just makes your life less than
completely [__] awesome
yeah so ask yourself what what is your
vision for your life to be the maximum
completely [__] awesome that it can
be and then
draw your road map to that being your
reality and let nothing [__]
interfere with the the
[__] mission to make it down that
path and be that awesomeness
yeah and I don't think they're getting
[__] stoned and [__] up like even
like it's part of that path no dude it's
not it's not and I I mean I I got I
cleaned up completely because of almost
dying from an overdose there you go I'm
like so I know where it leads me was it
was it just one overdose that that did
it for you yeah and you were like I
don't want to do that anymore yeah yeah
with drugs see it wasn't cocaine that
wasn't it man that's a scary overdose
yeah I mean it was it was it's like
seven day Bender mixed with you know
a couple other things along the way but
yeah so people hadn't been walking
around at that point yeah even though
we're not there yeah yes
we'll leave it with that dude like ask
yourself what's the [__] awesomest
version of my life that I can possibly
make real and uh and
let that be the the north star that
guides your next steps
dude thank you yeah thank you thank you
dog yeah yeah that was great yeah really
appreciate it hell yeah for sure do you
like shopping on Amazon I do and good
news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stevo's butthole destroyer
and Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right now
yeah dude